We're switching things up a bit.
It's hot out there.
Humid.
Of course, people still
stressed about COVID
and all the rest
so I thought, maybe we
should just get together
and kind of chill people out
with something we call
"Summer S'mores with Conan"
and of course, the Chill Chums.
(Matt laughing slowly)
Oh wow, that's great, Matt.
What a great laugh.
(Matt laughing)
That's a great laugh.
(all laughing)
Oh man.
I'm a Chill Chum!
That is not the laugh or the
demeanor of a Chill Chum.
That was horrible.
I think you're forgetting
the premise of this.
Sona and I are the Chill Chums
and we teach you to be chill.
And take it from a Chill Chum:
that's a Chill Chum Chuckle.
[Sona] Yeah.
Okay, well, I chafe at
your Chill Chum Chuckle.
[Matt] Ooh!
Yeah, I don't like it.
And also, I resent this whole idea
that I'm the uptight,
you know, type A Grinch.
I think that I'm very
capable of being zen.
[Matt] Hmm.
[Sona] Ah.
And doing my Buddha belly breathing.
[Sona] What?
I think I exude calm.
Well the fact
that you resent this means
that you're not very chill,
'cause a Chill Chum would
just let it, you know,
blow over him.
Yeah but you really grate.
When you're sitting there going,
"Hey, be a Chill Chum!"
and I can see you 'cause
we're on a Zoom call right now
and I can see that you
have banjos behind you.
One banjo.
You have four banjos, I'm counting them.
[Sona] What?
What?
You have an array
of tweed hats with feathers
in them, Tyrolean--
You have a vintage guitar
and a bust of Teddy Roosevelt behind you.
No, the bust of Teddy
Roosevelt was torn down.
It was ripped down by,
some protestors got into my house
and tore down my bust of Teddy Roosevelt.
(all laughing)
And by protestors I mean my two children.
(laughing) My daughter and my son came in
and tore it down.
Let's not start this with animosity.
Being a Chill Chum is
all about being friends.
I know, you're already, like,
breaking all kinds of chill rules.
[Matt] Yeah.
Well, okay.
[Sona] You're like, anti-chill.
Your chill factor is zero, man.
You're the opposite of chill.
If we come into this chill,
you, like, de-chill us.
So you just gotta--
That's right.
You're a Heat Miser.
Just chill, man.
You know, it's nice to
have two Chill Chums
that just tell me everything
that's wrong with me,
barrage me with criticism.
That really does help
create a chill environment.
[Matt] Hey, man.
[Conan] Hey, man.
[Sona] Just chill,
just chill.
[Conan] I'm a Chill Chum.